80% of humanity's papers are not cited
once so so so let's just translate that
for the viewing public yes that means
that they're producing scholarship that
nobody looks at yes but that even their
friends don't look at and and because
okay so what a citation is is I read
someone's paper and I find a good idea
in it and then I use that idea to
buttress an idea of my own or to or to
or to riff off or to or to or to
criticize even for that matter and then
I cite them I say who they were and when
they published it and then the paper the
SIA that there's a huge bureaucracy that
keeps track of citations and it's a
major indication of academic ability to
be cited right it's it's the it's like
it's academic payment to be cited okay
so 80 percent of humanities papers don't
get cited once it's absolute failure
absolute failure as a game if someone
wanted to play a game I would suggest
that they go and they look at the
publication's of the professor's in a
particular area and see if the titles
all sound the same and if they all say
something about intersectionality
colonialism and and these other various
social justice words you might wonder am
I going to get taught the same course
again and again by every professor in
this program because it seems to me that
all of their researches is very similar
and how can that be when there's such a
broad base of knowledge in the world
that we can have such similarity between
every publication which then goes on why
why do I need to read my colleague stuff
when it's exactly like my own which
which we see so just just as a baseline
Jordan look what would you say is is
someone who's doing some good research
what's how many citations would would
they be receiving maybe collectively
like what are we loans thousand yeah
well a good like if you if you write a
good paper then like a great paper paper
we'll get you a hundred citations right
an outstanding overwhelmingly
outstanding paper I'll get you at
thousand citations ten isn't none you
know it register with ten but zero is
that's failure right it means your work
had zero impact it it means your work
wasn't worth the paper it was published
on and this this brings us to a kind of
interesting little issue with regards to
the rot in the universities which which
Deborah McLeod she says does not exist
it's like here's how the game works is
that we set up a little ideological
garden right the ten of us play in and
then we all publish in the same journal
and we peer review each other's articles
and we just publish them there's no
critique or very little so the the
barrier for publication is very very low
when it should be very high like a good
journal a good journal will reject 90%
of the papers that are that are
submitted to it right so rejection rates
really matter so the question is why do
the these papers get published since no
one reads them and they have nothing to
offer and the answer to that it's very
straightforward the journals are
extremely expensive are way more
expensive than they should be so just to
buy a single paper online for the
ordinary person is like forty dollars
which is more than a hardcover book
that's just to download the PDF and so
the journal itself the libraries are
full of them are very expensive and the
subscriptions are very expensive and so
what happens is the professors pressure
the university libraries to buy the
journals and the library funds the
publisher and so the publishers will
publish anything Routledge is a good
example of that much to my chagrin
because they published my first book but
and they used to be a great publishing
house but they'll publish damn near
anything and the reason for that is that
the libraries are forced to pay
radically inflated prices for the
publications that no one ever reads and
so people write to publish in journals
that libraries have to purchase at
inflated prices to produce knowledge
that no one will ever read and that's
the little scandal that plagues the
humanities I think it characterizes the
humanities more than plagues them